[Music]
who has been the most like where you
guys got starstruck know that they slide
into your DMS we know that you strike up
friendships I'd sent him a little I say
hey you probably look at this but this
is Justin and I'm making a quiche this
Easter and if you want to come by I knew
he's in Brooklyn or something just used
with Anthony and he immediately hit me
back I was like oh my god what about
Justin Theroux because he's named you
guys and told some funny stories about
you guys have he come to you for any
advice at all about anything talk a lot
about product but he's actually like
really smart and well-educated when it
comes to like everything so he's really
a Renaissance man and really doesn't
need so much advice he's very smart
yeah yeah well he actually gives very
good advice on hot sauce he loves a good
yuzu infused hot sauce I'll say that and
he's just a store that I'd never been to
so he he's given loads of suggestions
he's actually great
[Music]
queer eyes fab 5 opening up to et about
their bromance with Justin Theroux at
Netflix and glisten screening of their
four-time emmy-nominated show I know
that so many celebrities have been
reaching out to you guys justin theroux
and a stone any chance we'll see a
celebrity on season well I will feel I
will say this much the biggest of the
big of the big of the big of the most
major earthmoving earth-shattering
cameos could maybe happen Barack Obama I
don't know my middle name isn't spoiler
and you need to stop your trade school
pushing is that it would be
earth-shattering gonna be very major
anymore leaf it about but I also feel
like what I said the j-school president
came off like more mean when I met were
too
[Music]
[Applause]